so our demo is going to be about
creating a calculator using react and
node.js
and so we have here just a basic
calculator nothing crazy
um but the whole thing is going to be
created with react
and so we'll be using javascript to be
installing react
and installing the various components
such as node.js
and the different npm solutions that we
need so as you can see
my calculator works just fine and now
let's go ahead
and let's go and
install the different tools that we need
so the first one is going to be node.js
and we do google search on node.js we
always start with google searches
because it's the easiest way to find
things
and so we go to the default node.js site
and you can go to downloads and there
are
windows mac os and also linux installers
you can also download the
original source code and compile it
yourself if you want and you'll also
need a text editor i'm going to be using
visual studio code it's just my favorite
text editor it's free works across all
platforms
uh it comes with a ton of extensions so
you can get up and running really
quickly with it
um so we're just going to go ahead and
install the windows version i already
have installed so you have to
download it again you also want to make
sure that you have the latest version
of node.js installed now with that node
package manager so we're just going to
open up our terminal window and validate
which version that we have
running and
we can do that fairly easily we can
just put in node version
and it'll tell us which version and
which means that's installed and the
same thing with npm
node package manager we'll do npm
version and that will give us back the
version number again you have to have
them installed for them to be able to
uh do that and we're going to also now
create a react
app so we're going to do install and
then it's going to be create dash react
app that's the command to create a new
react
app
and we're going to install it right off
our desktop
so let's go in and we'll put mpx
create dash react dash app
and then the app is going to be called
calculator which will install
a folder on our desktop with all the
appropriate react
code and this will be just a
template application but it'll have
everything there that we need to get
started with
hit return and that will take a few
minutes just to install everything
and here we go
and so as we go through some of the
components that we're going to be
creating today we're going to be
creating an app component and they'll be
the main component that has
all the information that will then be
disabled on the screen then we have a
layout component
and that will be the actual look and
feel of the calculator
and the output component which will be
the results from the calculator
and then the output row and this will be
all the different tools that we will
need
and here we have our new folder right
there
on our desktop but we're actually going
now into visual studio
and if you've seen any of the other
node.js videos that we've created you
know that i like to
work with the node.js in visual studio
code
um because i can run terminal window
right there so i'm going to open up the
folder that we just created
that's called calculator and we open up
the whole folder
not a file but the whole folder and
here's our folder on the left hand
side we have all the different files
there's our json package that has the
instructions for
what the calculator looks like
including which version of react and the
dom
and here's our default uh element
as you can see because we're using react
it's going to
embed the code into a html page and so
we have a div
with the id of root that's going to
reference um
some class files that we create and so
the app.js file
has the application code that we're
going to be modifying in a little bit
and you'll see that it actually then
references up to our
index.js file
and if in index.js file it has the
id element root which ties back to
the id element of root in our html file
so
we're constantly referencing and cross
referencing our application
and this is where we're going to be
doing most of our work
right so we're going to go ahead and
open up the terminal window
and the first thing we want to do is
start
npm
and it's now going to have everything
running on
let's have localhost and everything
running on port 3001
we'll give that a moment and this will
actually then bring up just the standard
default react boilerplate app
it's just taking a moment to load
i should probably get a faster computer
okay there we are uh just not patient so
here we have our basic boilerplate
react js application nothing to create
crazy here so let's actually go in and
start
working in some of our code so
let's see now yep everything is running
where we expect it to run
all right so let's go into fjs
and we can actually go ahead and if you
want to type control plus c
and actually stop the app or you can um
in the terminal window you can actually
stop it
now you can also go up into the terminal
command to stop it as well
and if we do stop the app then we'll get
an error message
there we go site can't be reached
and you'd expect this
we go back in and
we're going to just restart our
application
everything should now be working just
fine
we're going to refresh the page and
we'll
see our default react app
[Music]
there we are
looking good looking good
okay so we're going to delete out what
we have there because we want to put in
our
own content
and we're going to call this one class
app and we're going to go in and we're
going to be
modifying that class here in just a
moment
we'll put in default layout
i'm going to create a new folder
this folder is going to be called
components this is going to be for our
calculator
and put a new file in there i'm going to
call this one layout.js
and this is where we're going to start
breaking down the structure of our
layout
and we're going to
say import
layout and then
we want to do the path to our layout
components layout you necessarily have
the dot because we have to go up one
folder that's the command for that
so dot up one folder components folder
layout
notice we don't have to type layout.js
it automatically knows
to add the js extension
constantly making sure that we're saving
let's go over to layout.js
and this is our layout
and we do this using css
then we're going to import react
from react
and then select import
and then we're going to link to layout
css let's give you a css file that we're
going to create
so we're going to have to type that into
layout.css
and notice we had to write out
explicitly that it's a css file
and so here we have
and then we're going to put in
[Music]
the constructions for the layout
what our props look like
and then we'll export default layout so
it can
show up correctly
okay so we'll go to our web page now
yep that's good we're expecting to see
that so we need to
change some of our pathing here just
quite quickly
so let's see now
we're gonna move a file so it can be
accessed appropriately
we run this
you know what i think we didn't we have
to update
uh yep i know we have to go back to
layout and
we have to start adding in some values
here
so that the application knows to lay
content out so we just put in
a hello world
there we are okay so that shows us
everything is pulling through
correctly
so we want to get rid of hello because
we're going to replace that with our own
application
i'm going to change this div so that it
actually starts
pulling in the
and i'm application to put in the class
name for calculator
and this will be a css reference
okay so you need to have some image
files
and what we're doing here is we're
essentially building up the
different elements that will need to be
presented on the screen
and then we'll have a css file that
we'll use to create these elements
and as you can imagine i've i've already
got this written so i'm cheating a
little bit because i know what i'm
putting here
um but as bottom line is that
the calculator really is a bunch of
form elements such as buttons
on the screen but we use css to reformat
them so it looks more like a traditional
calculator
um that's one of the the things that
you get comfortable working with when
you're doing web applications
is how to take technologies that you're
used to using
and then modifying them so that they
look
different and so in this instance we're
used to using
button elements within an application so
why not use the the same bottom elements
which
consistently work from browser to
browser
and then just simply update the look and
feel of them with some css so that
they they look good and here we are just
doing a very simple
on click command um this is
some basic javascript that will render
inside of the
browser itself
okay so now we see boom there's a button
all right so and again you want to be
constantly testing and verifying
that the code you're writing is working
correctly
and we're going to do another button
and this is going to be the delete
button
so we've got we're going to start
building out our different buttons here
so let's start delete now we have an
i'll click
event for that
okay we're just doing some formatting
here
okay so we just used
going through our code here making sure
everything looks good
and one of the things we can now do
because we've got a base line
that looks correct we can just copy that
and then we want the percentage sign and
then the
forward bracket so this
so it gives us our two buttons so we
have a
it's got a new row here
i'm just going to copy everything over
just make it a little bit easier
ourselves
and then we're just going to pin the
numbers
seven eight nine
and then
plus single sorry the multiply symbol
and we'll be able to move these into
multiple rows here in just a moment
and we just want to keep going through
making all the changes here so we
actually fill out all the different
elements
so as you can see most of this isn't
really
complex it's just the
uh you use the word fiddly yeah i guess
again the
the fiddly parts of putting this content
together
so we refresh our screen start seeing
all the different elements
okay i can get it
we'll have to come back and make some
updates
to our css class names
and then we do our final three buttons
across the bottom
[Music]
okay so let's now add some styles to the
content that we've created
we do then our layout.css file
um so we already have some styles that
we created so we're just going to go
ahead
and for the for the sake of brevity
we're just going to
pull those over
we can if you want to um and have us do
a more detailed video on how to create
csc
css files and um you know yeah we'll
certainly do that but i think most you
probably know how to do this already
all right so here's our css file and so
we have our calculator
keys our buttons and the different types
of button here
so we can just copy these all over and
so these these will have the background
color the
border color et cetera et cetera and so
we're going to do that
here we have our
buttons for our app
easy way you know how
okay so we take out the css and we just
have basic buttons we have the css link
back in
we have nice laid out application
so we've got a couple of areas that are
still missing we've got the results
screen and the
uh default logo so
let's go ahead and add that information
in
and we'll create a new folder called
assets and the assets will put
another folder called font
and that'll be where our fonts will be
and then we'll create another folder
we'll call this one
images
and we'll put our images in there
so we have our logo image just simply
learn logo
and then for layout we can then just
reference that you know image reference
so i'm going to import the logo
i'm going to import that from
our assets folder and under assets we'll
go to img which we have our image
and then we'll do the path for the
logo.png
so remove this
and then we'll do source
and we'll do the source is from
our logo variable which is the as the
import of the image
i'll put the width and we have to know
it's 150 pixels and the
there we go 750 pixels wide
and the style that we will reference
from css
will be
block so just some inline styling here
generally normally do this i normally
have all my styling in my css
folder but uh in this instance because
we're just
putting up a solution i want you to be
able to see that you can actually do
this
in line so there we are however that
logo
okay so now we need to have the results
screen make sure that looks correct
okay and so we're going to create a new
folder and this is going to be got our
output
js file and this is going to control the
output in that blue screen
and put our react objects
and we'll export that
and we'll put a new file called
outputrow.js
so we'll put our instructions
and this is going to be our component
the users will put their
results into
and now put row
put our instructions here so we're going
to like export
default output row
all right so we're going to start
putting together the code that allows us
to construct
our solution and we're going to update
the output row.js file
and we're going to
add in our return value
so we'll put a div
and this will be
input type
so essentially we have a text field um
that will be read only on the top
of our calculator and here we see our
text field here
and that will allow us to be able to
put in our values
and we use the class screen that allows
us to give our formatting
and we're going to put a file it's going
to be output road or css we're going to
add in our
specific css for
this output row
[Music]
and as you can see we're just using all
of our standard html5
skill sets here
and let's go over to our
style it will pull in
uh props dot text size
and then the default um value
and so this is going to line with uh
go over to our css file and we'll update
that
and output.js
make sure the results get returned
correctly
as we're tapping on the buttons
and so this will pull in our output row
and the value will be
we bring that text size for our output
flow here
[Music]
and we're just going to put some sample
css styling here
nothing too crazy
and we have two rows
save that
our two rows will appear in a moment
let's go into our layout
let's add in our rows
so this is our output
pull in those values
and there we have our two values
and so we can apply some css styling to
this
so the top row will be the calculation
broken
out as we've written it and the bottom
row will be the results
and it's going to our css file here
we're going to copy over some css
and you have some
font styling we have our screen class
name
there's our screen here again this is
nothing no rocket science here and we've
done any css
um editing you'll be familiar with what
we've done here
then you see they're referring to a font
asset we actually have the font in there
we have to
pull that font over and and
it's just a ttf font true type font
you can use and any of the internet
fonts as well
google has a massive library of fonts
and there we are i'm going to change the
size of
our font so that the second row the text
is a little bit bigger
a little bit smaller and we don't have
anything wired up yet
we'll do that in a moment that'll be the
easy part of this assignment
all right so let's go over and
now lay out
okay so net input
set input
and use state
now can default the initial state
and for the result the you state
the initial usage will be just blank
there we are just what you'd expect to
see
so the results um are blank and this is
just when you run the app for the very
first time
okay so we're going through
and now we want to put in our actions so
we can have an event
when we click on any of the buttons
you want to take the value of the button
and so this you're going to be
any of these actions here
and we're just going to put together a
script to do the calculations
so as you can see so far we've put most
of this application
most of the hard work has been setting
up the base
react application putting together the
different files and folder structure
making sure we have the correct assets
such as images
fonts css files
laying out our core structure in html
form elements and now the
part that we're doing at the end here is
putting together the script
that will actually write that actually
do
our calculator uh events and
and honestly and this is going to be um
i've got this running here it's just
javascript so there are
lots of javascript calculators on the
internet so you can actually take any of
those
and use those as a base
for what we're doing here
there we have an if there's an error
we'll do math error a result
we don't expect to see that
and we'll just keep putting together our
code here
there are different results
so depending on
um which commands you use
so for instance the equal sign
and have the results
so we're using the value to actually
then trigger
what we would actually be seeing in
which screen okay
that's looking good so
we'll capture our value and this is all
concatenated together
and if there are any error messages
so if the value is c from the button so
if we select c
so we want to set the input to zero
which is to reset
the screen
and if the value
equals and this will be delete
what we want to do is we want to
manipulate the string on the screen
which means we're going to eliminate
the last character entered
and this is manipulation here
and this is all reducing the length of
the string
by one character at a time
again this is your standard javascript
control so we hit delete
and that gets rid of a character another
character
hit it again i'll get rid of the third
character
[Music]
and
and put if the string is
zero then put that as the value all
right
this allows us to test out our
application
all looking good so far
okay i want to make sure that we're then
calculating our values correctly
and here we have the
display and the input
it's all coming from here our output
class
and then we'll put in our results
okay it looks like we're letting lining
everything up just always
want to go back and double check that
you have all your commands
or your variables lining up correctly
eliminate those
and we'll make sure we have the answer
and the
user entered there
and we have the answer in the user and
we'll change the font size
you say that we'll go over and this is
now this is our local application
and we test it we can start putting
together our construct
and we'll see that our calculator is
working so clear gets rid of
both values
everything's looking pretty good
and here we have our first application
and
this is the sample application uh
this is the application we just wrote
here is the original application that we
were testing against
and as you can see everything lined up
correctly and so you've seen how in just
45 minutes you can actually
write out your own
react js application with node.js
and so we terminate the application
so this is the one we just built
it's going to fail so that
allows us to validate that we actually
created
we'll restart the services
say yes i'm running on another port
because we already have an app running
on
another port so it's going to run on
3001
refreshing the web page
voila there we are there's our
application up and
running everything looks
really good working fine
it works absolutely identically
now if you want to you could actually
then take this application
and make it a native application as well
right now we're just using as a web
application
we're just updating some of the css
making it a little bit tighter
everything looking exactly the same
there you go that's your app all up and
running
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here